هذه اثار القصف الاسرائيلي لقصف قوات
الاحتلال لشقه
سكنيه في منزل عائله يتبع لعائله ابو عجوى
في محيط مستشفى الشفاء عدد كبير من
الشهداء والاصابات في هذه
المنطقه يحاول
الاهالي
انتشال جثامين الشهداء والاصابات من اسفل
الانقاظ تم اخراج الكثير من الاصابات من
اسفل هذه الانقاظ بنجاح حتى هذه اللحظه
المحاولات
[موسيقى]
مستمره المدات بسيطه
جدا الاهالي يحاول انتشال كل ما
تبقى اسفل
هذا هذه
البنايه هي امراه طبعا
استشهدت
طبعا نحن الان في مقابل مستشفى الشفاء هذا
المكان
هو مباني مستشفى الشفاء تم قصف هذه
البنايات شقتين سكنيتين
بالتوازي مقابل بعضهما البعض دمرت هذه
الشقه بشكل كامل او الطوابق الاخيره
بالتحديد من هذه البنايه بشكل
كامل طفل صغير لم يبلغ العام عالق اسفل
الانقاض يحاول الاهالي انتشاله من اسفل
الانقاض لا اعطيه اعطيه ناوله ناوله ناوله
ها عبد الله هذا الطفل تم انتشاله من اسفل
الانقاض بعد محاولات طويله
[موسيقى]
من حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل قهم اشلاء بنطلع
اشلا
طب حتى هذه اللحظه الاهالي يعملون على
تجميع الاشلاء
المتناثره بشكل
فعلي اشلاء الدماء في كل مكان هناك عدد
كبير من الشهداء هم
اشلا اسماعيل القول الجزيره مدينه غزه